and now we have women that they're
really they're they're giving them
diversity hires and it's obvious to
everyone around them that they're
diversity hires because really women
can't handle stress like men can you
know and a lot of people it's so funny a
lot of people look to me as an example
be like Pearl aren't you like doing this
high stress job I'm like I talk
for a living you think that's as hard as
building a building do you think I you I
have it in me to go build that building
next door oh no
oh no no no no I'm like I talk and I
tweet don't get me wrong there's some
things that are stressful I am a hard
worker but compare that to the real
dirty jobs of this Society like do you
remember the show Dirty Jobs and I
actually have an issue because a lot of
the streamers will look down on the men
that do these dirty jobs as if they are
somehow better more confident or smarter
than them